The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: So this is
on oxidation--reduction go.
GUEST SPEAKER: OK, so the demo
involves a strip of magnesium.
And the magnesium is a
pretty reactive metal.
Right now it's coated
with magnesium oxide.
And what I'm going to do is
I'm going to light it on fire.
When it gets lit, it's going
to glow very, very brightly,
and it's going to react with
this block of carbon dioxide.
And magnesium oxide is
what you have up there.
Both of those magnesium
oxide molecules
will react with one
molecule of carbon dioxide
to form just graphene, carbon,
as well as magnesium dioxide.
So you're going to get
a white and black powder
inside of here.
And it's going to be really
bright and really dangerous.
And can we lower the lights?
Is that something we
can do, because that
makes it a whole lot more fun?
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
CATHERINE DRENNAN: You can
try it one more time, OK?
All right.
OK, good try.
So oxidation-reductions
are really fun.
And so we're going to
continue and tell you
about those on Friday.
So oxidation-reduction,
or redox-- so
redox is the shorthand
for oxidation-reduction.
Let's bring out your hands,
but let's bring the noise level
down.
People have still
been complaining
about the noise in class.
All right, so a redox
reaction, a chemical reaction
that involves an
exchange of electrons.
And so we saw what happens when
we mix this with some dry ice.
All right, so let's
do some definitions.
We always start units
with definitions.
And most of you know some of
these definitions already.
Oxidation, electron loss.
Reduction, electrons are gained.
This one you may or may
not be familiar with.
Oxidizing agent, it
accepts electrons.
So it oxidizes other things,
but it itself is reduced.
And reducing agent
donates electrons.
It reduces other things.
It itself is oxidized.
And before you turn
the page, I just
want to try to get you to
remember these two terms.
So one way that I
like to think about it
is that a reducing
agent might be somebody
who is a little bit shady.
They might walk up to someone
and say, in a crowded space,
don't look at me, just listen.
Do you want to buy an electron?
So that would be an agent
of reduction going around.
Now, there could be ones
that are a little bit
shady, selling electrons
to the highest bidder.
But there could also
be agents of good.
I told you about
free radical species.
There's a lot of free
radicals in the universe.
They can be dangerous
because they
have a single, unpaired
electron, which makes
them really highly reactive.
So there might be an agent,
a secret agent of oxidation.
And it might want to shield
the universe from the power
of free radicals.
And so it will go along
and it would oxidize that,
take that electron
away and oxidize
and become reduced itself,
take that free radical away.
Because the free radical species
might not know how dangerous
it is.
It's for everybody's good to
shield you from that power.
You might also have
an agent of reduction
that's a secret
agent, that might
go up to the free
radical species
and give it an extra electron.
And then it has two.
And then it's more
stable and less reactive.
So you might have these agents.
So that's how you
should think about it.
Think about an
agent of oxidation
wants to go out and oxidize
for the good of mankind,
or an agent of reduction that
wants to go out and reduce
other things.
So that might help you
remember those definitions.
We'll hope so.
All right, so let's take
a look now-- we always
start every unit
with definitions,
and then we have a set
of rules and guidelines.
So let's take a look
at the guidelines.
Luckily, these guidelines are
really pretty straightforward.
And you really shouldn't have a
lot of difficulty keeping them
in mind.
Some of them we've
really seen already,
we just didn't
realize that they were
going to be the guidelines
that we would have.
So guidelines for assigning
oxidation numbers--
in a free element, every
atom has an oxidation number
of zero.
OK, that seems pretty
straightforward.
H2, oxidation number, zero.
Rule two-- ions composed
of only one atom,
also called monatomic ions,
have an oxidation number
that's equal to their charge.
If this wasn't true, it
would be deeply disturbing.
Lithium plus 1 ions has an
oxidation number of plus 1.
I think we're good.
Also in number two,
in forming compounds,
compounds Group 1 metals
have an oxidation number
of plus 1, lithium and all of
its friends, sodium, et cetera.
Group 2 metals have an oxidation
number of plus 2-- calcium
for example.
And aluminum is plus
3 in its compounds.
This is also something
that we've seen before.
Those Group 1 and Group 2 metals
are not all that exciting.
They pretty much want to get
their noble gas configuration
and they want it to lose either
one, if you're in Group 1,
or two electrons if
you're in Group 2.
And so that's what they do here.
So this is good to keep
in mind because it's
going to help you
figure out the oxidation
number of other elements
for which there are not
such hard and fast rules.
Number three, oxygen-- oxygen
in most compounds is minus 2.
Again, not that surprising
that it would want
to gain those two electrons.
However, there's
some exceptions.
Oxygen is just an element
full of exceptions.
If it is in peroxides-- hydrogen
peroxide, O2, 2 minus-- then
it's going to have an
oxidation number of minus 1.
So peroxides, and later we'll
see superoxides are exceptions.
But if it's not a
peroxide or a superoxide,
it's going to be minus 2.
All right, rule number
four, hydrogen-- hydrogen
is mostly plus 1.
You probably could guess that.
But there actually are
some exceptions for this.
And you're going to see a lot of
those exceptions in this unit,
and pretty much after this
unit, not so much ever again.
The exceptions are for the
Group 1 and the Group 2.
So the Group 1 and Group
2 rules supersede the fact
that hydrogen is usually plus 1.
So if you have
hydrogen with lithium,
lithium is going to be plus 1.
So hydrogen will be minus. one.
Sodium is the same here.
And calcium, that's Group 2.
Again, hydrogen
would be minus 1.
So Group 1, Group 2
rules supersede hydrogen.
All right, what
about our halides?
We have fluorine.
It wants to be minus 1.
Other halogens--
chloride, bromide,
iodide-- are negative
when they are in salts,
such as sodium chloride.
But if oxygen is
there, the oxygen rules
are the ones that follow.
So here, if you
have Cl with oxygen,
then you're going to
have a positive oxidation
number for the
chlorine, because oxygen
is going to be minus two.
And you'll see a number of
these so-called oxyacids
in this unit.
All right, six-- this one,
you probably already know.
But in a neutral molecule, the
sums of the oxidation numbers
must equal zero.
So the sums must be neutral
if the molecule is neutral.
And if you have something that
is a polyatomic multiatom ion,
the sum of the individual
oxidation numbers
needs to be equal to the
overall charge on that ion.
So again, we've seen
things like this before.
So we should have no
trouble with these words.
OK, so let's just look
at an example of this.
Suppose we have our
friend NH4 plus.
What is hydrogen's
oxidation number going to be
in this molecule?
It will be plus one.
So it's not with a Group
1 or Group 2 element,
so it's going to be plus 1.
What about nitrogen?
There were no rules
about nitrogen,
so we have to figure out
based on the other rules what
the oxidation number
of nitrogen will be.
What is it going to be here?
AUDIENCE: Minus 3.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: It's
going to be minus 3.
And the reason for that
is because of the rule
we just talked about, that the
sum of the oxidation numbers
needs to be equal to the
charge on the molecule.
The charge is plus 1.
So we have four hydrogens,
4 plus 1 minus 3
is going to equal plus 1.
So nitrogen would
have to be minus 3.
Nitrogen can have a lot
of different numbers,
so you want to pay attention
to what's around it
and whether there are
rules or guidelines
about those other elements.
All right, seven,
oxidation numbers
don't have to be integers.
They almost always are, but
there is one notable exception,
and it's from oxygen.
Perhaps not a surprise,
oxygen is always
causing trouble.
So in superoxide,
you have O2 minus 1.
So what is the oxidation
number on each oxygen
in that O2 minus one molecule?
Yep, so it's minus 1/2.
So oxygen is usually minus
2 except in peroxides
and superoxides.
All right, so let's take
a look at some examples.
And I'll write some
of these on the board.
And here are all of your rules.
So you can yell
out what you think
I should be doing with
these as we go along.
OK, so we have lithium 2 oxide.
So here we know
a lot about this.
What's the oxygen
going to be-- minus 2.
The overall charge on
the molecule is zero.
And we have two lithiums.
And what's the
charge on each one?
AUDIENCE: Plus 1.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Plus 1.
And so plus 2 minus 2 is 0.
Great.
Let's do another one.
We'll do PCl5 next.
So what do we know about Cl?
What charge do we expect here?
AUDIENCE: Minus 1.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Minus 1,
and there are five of those.
So chlorine likes to be minus 1.
Exception is with oxygen, but
it's not with oxygen here.
The overall charge is going
to be zero, because it's
a neutral molecule.
So what does that mean about
the charge on our phosphorous?
AUDIENCE: Plus 5.
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
Plus 5, right.
OK, so now let's try HNO3.
So let's do oxygen first.
What charge do we
expect on oxygen?
AUDIENCE: Minus 2.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Minus 2.
So we have three
of those minus 2.
Overall this is
going to be zero.
Nitrogen can be varied,
so let's do hydrogen. What
do we expect hydrogen to be?
AUDIENCE: Plus 1.
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
Plus 1, right,
because it's not in
Group 1 or Group 2.
So what does that
leave for nitrogen?
AUDIENCE: Plus 5.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Plus 5.
So we have plus 6
then minus 6 is 0.
All right, so why don't
you try the next one
as a clicker question.
All right, 10 more seconds.
So oxygen is minus 2.
It's not in a peroxide
or a superoxide.
The overall charge is zero.
So that means that each
nitrogen must be plus 1.
So we have plus 2 minus 2 is 0.
AUDIENCE: Professor?
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What
exactly is a peroxide?
CATHERINE DRENNAN: A peroxide--
so there really only goes
the hydrogen peroxide example.
So it'll say that it's a
peroxide, or a superoxide.
You don't have to
worry about that.
It's going to be clear.
OK, good.
So now let's talk
about some reactions
that involve oxidations
and reductions.
And to talk about
these reactions you
need to know how to do this.
And then we're going to talk
about balancing reactions.
And you need all
of these skills.
All right, so first I just want
to tell you about something
called the
disproportionation reaction
where you have one element
that is going to be
both oxidized and reduced.
And this is a good
example to allow
us to think about
what's happening
in a different reaction.
So in this reaction,
the element that
is going to be both
oxidized and reduced is Cl.
Sodium is going to
be a spectator ion.
And the oxygen is going to
stay in its minus 2 form here.
And so we have chlorine going
to chlorine in this compound
and in this compound.
So we can break
this down and think
about what's happening with
this species going to this,
and then also going to Cl minus.
So let's think about what the
oxidation number of chlorine
is in ClO minus.
So first, oxygen, I already told
you, is going to be minus 2.
The overall charge on
the molecule is minus 1.
So chlorine has to make
this equation work.
So what is the
oxidation number of Cl?
AUDIENCE: Plus 1.
AUDIENCE: Plus 1, thank you.
So yeah, plus 1 here.
Now let's take a look at this.
So oxygen, we're going
to have as minus 2.
There are three of them.
That's going to equal,
overall, minus 1.
So what's the oxidation
number of chlorine here?
AUDIENCE: Plus 5.
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
Plus 5, right.
So we have a case
now where we're
going from plus 1 to plus 5.
Is that an oxidation
or a reduction?
That's an oxidation.
So we're increasing the number.
It is losing electrons.
It's becoming oxidized.
So down here, we already
have done all of our work
and know that this is
also going to be plus 1.
So in this case, we're going
from plus 1 to minus 1.
Is that an oxidation
or a reduction?
AUDIENCE: Reduction.
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
That's a reduction,
and that's good
because it wouldn't
be a very good
disproportionation
reaction otherwise.
Something has to be oxidized.
Same thing has to be
oxidized and reduced.
So this is how you think
about this type of reaction.
So to consider
whether something's
being oxidized or
reduced, you need
to be able to dissect out what
the oxidation numbers are.
All right, now we're
going to balance.
So balancing is going
to become very important
for doing problems later on,
balancing redox reactions.
You balance
differently if you're
in acidic conditions
versus basic conditions.
So first we're going to
do acidic conditions.
And we're going to run through
the steps for doing this.
First step is we're
going to write two half
reactions for this.
So we have iron in here and
we have chromium in here,
and we're going to
separate those out.
So we're going to think about
what iron is doing separately
from what the chromium is doing.
So first, let's write
out our chromium
and think about what is
happening to it here.
And that is a clicker question.
All right, 10 more seconds.
OK, so let's take a look
at why two is correct.
For one thing, you just have
to remember the definitions.
For another, you have
to recognize what's
happening to the chromium.
So let's take a look
at the chromium now.
So we have oxygen at minus 2.
There's seven of them.
And the overall charge on
the molecule is minus 2.
And so what does that
mean for the oxidation
number of this chromium?
AUDIENCE: Plus 6.
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
It's going to be
plus 6, because we're going
to have 12 minus 14 equals
minus 2.
So we're going from plus 6
over here to plus 3 here.
So is that an
oxidation or reduction?
So that's a reduction.
So I kind of like this unit
coming after acids and bases
because a lot of those
problems, I think,
make people's brains
hurt a little bit.
And you get here and
it's, like, basic math.
So it's kind of exciting.
All right, so the
iron is even simpler.
We're going from
plus 2 to plus 3.
So that's an oxidation.
So one thing is being reduced.
The other thing
is being oxidized.
That's what makes
it a redox reaction.
All right, so we
know what's happening
in terms of what's being
oxidized, what's being reduced.
And we've broken these
into half reactions.
Now we need to balance.
All right, so the first
thing we're going to do
is we're going to balance
our elements that are not
oxygen and hydrogen. So we're
going to balance chromium
and we're going to
balance our iron.
What do we need to add to
this top to balance chromium?
We need to add a 2.
And we don't need to do
anything to our iron.
We have one iron on one side,
one iron on the other side.
All right, so all you need
to do is insert the 2.
Next step, we're going to
add water to balance oxygen.
So how much water do we need
to add to the top reaction
to balance the oxygen?
So here we're going to add seven
waters to balance the oxygen.
And again, we have
nothing to do down there.
All, right, so let's keep going.
Next, we want to
balance the hydrogen.
We're just added those waters.
And so now we have
to balance hydrogen.
So we're going to balance the
hydrogen by adding H plus.
Some books have you
balance the hydrogen
by adding a more
correct species, which
is hydronium ion.
But when you do that,
you screw up your oxygens
that you just balanced.
So that is infinitely harder
to balance equations that way.
So I say let's not do that.
So let's just use H plus.
So how many H pluses
do we need to add over
here to balance the hydrogen?
14-- you've added 14.
And again, you don't
have to do anything
to the bottom expression.
Next, we are going
to balance the charge
by inserting electrons.
So over here we have
14 minus 2 plus 12.
And over here we have plus 6.
So how many electrons are
we going to need to add?
We're going to need to add six.
So we've added six
over here, because they
have a negative charge.
So now we should be
balanced on both sides.
And now we finally
get to do something
with the bottom expression.
And we can add an electron over
here to balance the charge.
So plus 2 here, plus 2
net on the other side.
All right, now we want to
multiply so that the electrons
are going to cancel.
Because this is an overall
oxidation-reduction reaction,
our electrons should cancel.
So what do we need to multiply
the bottom equation by?
6, and there we go-- 6
here, 6 here, and 6 here.
Now this is one of the places
that people often, in exams,
make a mistake
where they write 6
and then put a parentheses
around it indicating
that you're multiplying
the whole thing by 6,
which is fine.
But then they forget to
actually carry that out
on the next step.
So when you multiply, make
sure that you continue
to-- sometimes it's better
to just write it all out,
because otherwise it's
really easy to forget and not
multiply, and then things
won't make sense at the end.
All right, so now we can
add the half reactions
and make the appropriate
cancellations.
So we've now added all together
six electrons, 14 H plus.
We have our chromium
oxide compound.
We have now our six iron plus
2s, our two chromium plus 3s,
our seven waters, our six iron
plus 3s, and our six electrons.
And if we did everything
right, then the electrons
should cancel.
And we can double check.
It's always a good
idea to double check
that it's balanced.
So we have 14 H's
here, 14 H's there.
Chromium two, two.
Oxygen seven, seven.
Iron, six, six.
This can catch a mistake
that you might have made.
And then check the
charge-- plus 14, minus 2,
plus 12 on one side.
Plus 6, plus 18, so
24 on both sides.
That's pretty good, right?
That's pretty simple.
So balancing.
That's an acidic solution.
We know it's in acidic
because we have 14 H plus.
That feels quite acidic.
What do you do for a
basic solution now?
So for a basic solution
what I recommend is just
do the exact same thing that you
did for your acidic solution.
And here again was the
answer that we have.
And then, quote, neutralize
the acid and make it basic.
Adjust your pH by adding
OH minus or hydroxide iron
concentration to each side.
So if we do that
now, we're going
to add 14 OH minus to this side
and 14 OH minus to that side.
Now 14 OH minus
plus 14 H plus are
going to give us 14 water
molecules over here.
And on this side we
still have 14 OH.
This is not simplified, because
we have 14 waters on one side
and seven on the other side.
So we can take that,
cancel out these seven.
And we have seven
left over here.
So we have seven
waters now on one side
and 14 hydroxides on the other.
So if we look at both of these
expressions in acidic solution
and in basic solution
here, in acidic solution
we have 14 H plus on one side
and seven waters on the other.
In basic we have seven
waters on this side and 14 OH
minus on this side.
Everything else
should be the same,
and they should all add up.
All right, so there we go.
That is balancing
oxidation-reductions.
It seems really straightforward,
but it's very important.
We'll see next week that we
need to use this information
to be able to do problems.
All right, so end of 14.
Now to electrochemistry--
so today's handout.
So we're talking about
oxidation-reduction.
We're continuing talking
about oxidation-reduction.
I just want to
remind you how really
important oxidation-reduction
reactions are.
So we've talked about
photosynthesis in this class.
We've talked about fuel cells.
All of these reactions
that make energy involve
oxidation-reduction, loss of
electrons, gain of electrons.
Basically the human
body is a big battery.
We have lots of
oxidation-reduction reactions
going on inside of us.
This is how we live.
This is how we make energy.
This is how we survive.
All right, so
electrochemistry is the study
of redox reactions,
usually thinking about how
they occur at an electrode.
So there are two
types of reactions
that you will be considering.
You might be considering
a reaction that
generates an electric current,
electron flow, or electricity,
from a spontaneous reaction.
And you might
consider one where you
need to drive a reaction
that is nonspontaneous
using an electric current.
So a spontaneous
reaction, delta G
is what, positive or negative?
AUDIENCE: Negative.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Right.
So a spontaneous reaction,
delta G is negative.
It's less than zero.
A nonspontaneous
reaction is positive.
Just a little review
there for exam three.
All right, so electrochemistry,
study of these redox reactions.
Electrochemical
cells are devices
where you generate electrons
and they flow through the cell.
And so you have the flow of
electrons through a circuit.
And again, that can be generated
by a spontaneous reaction.
And if it is generated by
a spontaneous reaction,
that's called a galvanic cell.
Or you can use an
electric current
to force a nonspontaneous
reaction to go.
And that's called an
electrolytic cell.
And it's important to
remember those definitions
because a lot of
problems tell you,
oh, in this electrolytic cell.
And that's telling you key
information about what's
going on in that problem.
So if you don't have these
committed to memories,
you will find
yourself in trouble.
But it's not too
bad, just two terms.
So a battery then-- so
I have a battery here.
A battery is a collection
of galvanic cells.
And it's going to
give us-- it's going
to use spontaneous reactions
to give us electric current.
And again, electrodes,
the definition for those,
they're just the
conductors through which
the electrons travel.
And there are two types.
Let's quiet down again.
I hear the noise.
Two types of electrodes--
we have anodes and cathodes.
All right, so let's look
at an electrochemical cell
and consider, again, the
anodes and the cathodes.
So this is my
beautiful depiction
of an electrochemical cell.
This might be a better
depiction of what it looks like,
but I think mine is not bad.
Just to help you
out, that's supposed
to be a beaker that
has fluid in it.
This is also a beaker
that has fluid in it.
And this is my electrode.
That is an anode in this case.
There is the anode there,
the electrode there.
Here's another one.
That's the cathode,
another type of electrode.
It's over here.
This is my salt bridge.
The salt bridge here
is this plastic tube.
And here I have a wire
connecting my electrodes here.
And you can't
really see the wire.
But in both cases it goes
through some kind of volt meter
that measures the
electric current.
All right, so now we get
rid of this better picture.
But you can think about this
pictures or that picture
if that helps.
And I always like
to joke that you
think you have a bad here
at MIT, in the old days,
before you could do your
problem set at 2 o'clock
in the morning you had to
build your own batteries
to be able to do it.
All right, so anode-- electrons
are produced from oxidation
at the anode.
So the electrons produced
here flow out of the cell.
And in this particular type
of electrochemical cell,
zinc solid is oxidized
to zinc plus 2.
So if we look at
this over here, this
is my little beautiful
depiction of the blow
up of the electrode.
We have our zinc solid here.
And we have zinc plus
2 in aqueous solution.
So when the electrons
leave the zinc solid,
so that the zinc then
leaves the electrode
and goes into solution,
forming zinc plus 2,
those electrons go out.
So the electrons will
then go into the cathode.
And notice I had a
typo in the handout.
I find this pretty funny.
I don't know if it's me
or spellcheck right now.
I wrote elections are consumed.
Oh man, it's been a long week,
between the national elections
and our T-shirt elections.
Anyway, I didn't mean elections.
I meant electrons.
Yes, of course,
electrons are consumed
by a reduction reaction.
Of course I noticed that after I
had printed hundreds of copies.
And this particular
reaction here, copper plus 2
is reduced to copper solid.
And if we look over
here, we have copper
plus 2 in aqueous solution.
When two electrons come
in, those two electrons
go to the copper plus 2 and
reduce it to copper solid.
And the copper solid actually
plates on the electrode.
So we can measure the flow.
We can have a
meter that measures
the volts or the
flow of electrons,
the electric current.
And also what's that
salt bridge doing?
Well, the salt bridge
can help maintain
the neutrality in the system.
Because over here, we're
generating plus charge.
And over here we're
losing plus charge.
And so ions can flow
through the salt bridge
and keep the charges
more similar in our two
different beakers.
All right, so I know my
pictures are gorgeous,
but I have a little animation
to show you that will also
show you what I
was talking about,
oxidation at the electrode.
Zinc solid is going to lose
electrons and form zinc plus 2.
And let me just show
you that happening.
So there are the
electrons going away.
And here is zinc popping
off as zinc plus 2.
And then the zinc plus 2
is going to be in solution.
So there the electrons go again.
And the zinc solid pops
off as zinc plus 2.
All right, so now let's consider
reduction at the cathode.
So here we have
our copper solid.
Here we have a copper plus 2.
And here the electrons are
going to come in and join up
with our copper plus 2.
And it's going to plate
onto the electrode.
There come the electrons.
There they come again.
And now we have added solid
copper to our electrode.
And just one more
time-- and I think
it's so cool that
we can just watch
those electrons move like that.
All right, so there's
our electrochemical cell
where we have an oxidation
and reduction reaction.
Instead of drawing this
admittedly beautiful picture
every time, we can have a
shorthand representation
for this.
So we can say zinc solid.
And then we have a
little line here.
That little line indicates
we have a phase boundary.
So that means we're going from
solid to a different phase.
And in this case we're going
to aqueous, so solid zinc
to zinc plus 2.
The two lines here
indicate the salt bridge.
So this tells us that
the reaction on this side
is in one beaker, and
is in our other beaker.
The reaction in
the other side is
copper plus 2 aqueous, a single
line for phase boundary going
to copper solid.
Now if we had, say,
two aqueous species,
we wouldn't have
a phase boundary,
we'd just have a comma.
But if you have a phase
boundary, you get the line.
All right, so it's a
clicker competition.
Let's consider another cell.
It still has zinc,
but now it has tin.
Why don't you tell me which
reaction is at the anode
and which reaction
is at the cathode?
And also, which of
those is oxidation
and which is reductions?
All right, we'll just
do 10 more seconds.
Great.
OK, so some of these
had parts of it right,
but there was a mistake.
We have AnOx, so that is wrong.
So you had to pay attention
to whether these match,
and then also that the
reaction is written consistent
with the word.
So only number two had all the
various different parts right.
So we can come back
here and you can
enter-- so the reaction at
the anode was a zinc reaction.
And that is an oxidation, AnOx.
The reaction at the cathode
is the tin reaction.
Tin plus 4, two electrons,
tin plus 2 aqueous.
And that's a reduction.
And while you have your
clickers out, why don't you
tell me how you would represent
that electrochemical cell?
All right, let's just
do 10 more seconds.
So right.
So I mentioned
this very briefly.
This was my tricky
clicker question,
because it's a competition.
So there's no phase transition
here, so you have a comma.
And the top one a few people put
down, but it's not solid here.
So that one is not correct.
So here you can write
down in your notes,
you have this zinc
phase transition,
zinc plus 2 aqueous.
And then we have our
salt bridge, zinc
plus 4 aqueous comma per zinc,
tin plus 4 comma, tine plus 2.
And now we're ready for winners.
We'll see if Sam's also
ready to present the winners.
All right, we need a strategy
to defeat Dan's recitation,
but we know what T-shirt
we're playing for now.
All right, have a great
weekend everybody.
All right, let's just
take 10 more seconds.
All right, does
someone want to tell me
how they got the right answer?
Yep?
AUDIENCE: You know that your
hydrogen will have a plus 1
charge, and your oxygen
will have a minus 2 charge
because it's not a peroxide.
And you know your sum
is going to be neutral.
So you add one.
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
Yep, that's right.
So this one, chlorine
is usually minus 1.
The exception is when
it's with oxygen.
And so oxygen is always
minus 2 unless it's
in a peroxide or superoxide.
And hydrogen's always
plus 1 except when
it's with a metal like sodium,
something Group 1 or Group 2.
OK, so today take
out lecture 25 notes.
We're just going to
wrap those notes up--
that shouldn't take
too long-- and then
keep going with lecture 26.
So we were talking
about this cell.
And we're going to talk about
this electrochemical cell
a lot.
So we had zinc on one
side, zinc at the anode.
And the zinc was being oxidized,
generating electrons, which
come around to the copper.
And then the copper
plus 2 ions were
being reduced to copper solid.
So the zinc anode
was being consumed.
And the copper cathode
had copper solid being
plated onto it.
So Faraday's law
says that the amount
in which an anode, like
the zinc anode, is consumed
and the amount of copper that
gets plated on at the cathode
is proportional to the charge
that passes through the system.
So according to
Faraday's law, there
is a proportionality
between the consumption
and also depositing of metal
and the amount of charge
going through the system.
So we can think about
how much zinc is consumed
and how much copper is deposited
on its cathode or its electrode
if you have a current of
1 amp flowing for 1 hour.
So let's just take a look at
how we do a problem like this.
First step is we
want to think about,
calculate the charge that's
going through the system.
And so Q here, we have another
Q-- not the reaction quotient,
but the magnitude of the charge.
And that's in coulombs.
And that's going to be equal
to the current times the time.
So we have the current, I.
And the current is in amps.
And t is in seconds.
And conveniently, amps
equal coulombs per second.
So this equation works out.
Our units will work out.
So Q is going to be equal
to-- we have 1.0 amps.
And it was 1 hour, so
that's 3,600 seconds,
or 3,600 coulombs, because
we have an amp times second.
And then here, we have
this number of coulombs.
And now we want to convert
to the number of moles
of electrons that that is
equivalent to, that that charge
in coulombs is equivalent to.
And here, our Faraday's constant
is our conversion factor.
So Faraday's constant, we
have 96,485 coulombs per mole
is one faraday.
And its this kind of
funny looking F over here.
So we have our coulombs.
So we can use now the
Faraday's constant to convert.
And we get 0.00373
moles of electrons.
So that's the number
of moles of electrons
that would be going through
our system that correspond
to that amount of charge.
All right, so now we
need to relate this back
to the zinc and the copper.
So step three, we
want to know first
the number of moles of the
zinc and copper involved,
and then convert that to grams
because the problem asked us
for grams.
So we have the number of
moles of electrons that
are going through the system.
And so for every one
mole of zinc consumed,
how many electrons
go into the system?
What's the ratio, one,
two-- how many electrons?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CATHERINE DRENNAN: So one zinc
solid going to one zinc plus.
AUDIENCE: Two
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Two.
So that's going to be
two moles of electrons.
And then we need to look
up, how are we going
to convert our moles to grams?
What are we looking up?
AUDIENCE: Molar mass.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Yep,
molar mass, molecular weight,
atomic mass.
So in our periodic
table, grams per mole.
And so we get 1.2 grams
here for this equation.
All right, so for copper,
so we have the same number
of moles of electrons that
are going through the system.
So for every one
mole of copper solid
deposited on its electrode,
how many moles of electrons
have to come into the system?
Louder?
AUDIENCE: Two.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Two, yes.
So that's two as well.
And then we look up again,
in the periodic table,
the atomic weight,
molecular weight.
And it's almost the
same, copper and zinc.
So to the number of
significant figures
it's the same amount of grams.
Now this will not
always be the case.
They're just very
close to each other
in their molecular
or atomic weight.
OK, so we have two
significant figures.
Also our current in time only
had two significant figures.
So we only have two significant
figures in this problem.
All right, so in this
particular electrochemical cell,
again, our anode
is being consumed
and the electrons
that were generated
ended up plating the copper on.
Sometimes you're not
going to want to do that.
Sometimes you're just going
to want to actually plate
something with
copper, for example.
And so let's look
at some of the uses
for this kind of chemistry.
So here's some electroplating.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- This steel spoon will
have a thin coating
of copper deposited on it.
The cell consists of an
anode of pure copper,
a solution of copper sulfate,
and as a cathode, a spoon.
There is no net reaction.
The copper metal is transferred
from the anode to the cathode.
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
It's pretty nice.
[END PLAYBACK]
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
OK, so is kind
of electroplating is
pretty common where
you use these kind of reactions
to get your copper, which
is in that solution, to plate
as copper solid onto something.
So it could be a spoon.
It could be an electrode.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why is it dangerous?
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
Why is it dangerous?
You know, I've seen
these demos before,
so I think that's
just like security
[INAUDIBLE] to say that.
I don't think it's
incredibly dangerous frankly,
but I probably
shouldn't say that.
I'll get myself in
all sorts of trouble.
Don't try this at home.
I don't know why.
AUDIENCE: Usually when you're
doing jewelery plating,
the chemicals that you
use are relatively toxic.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Yeah,
but not that much worse
than the lab stuff.
Allena makes jewelry, so
she knows all about this.
But she does it very
safely-- very safely.
All right, so let's look
at a couple other kinds
of electrodes.
It is not always the case
that an electrode is consumed
or that an electrode gets
stuff deposited on it.
Some electrodes are inert.
An example for this is
a platinum electrode.
It is inert.
So it doesn't get
consumed and it
doesn't get reacted onto
during the reaction.
And so here's an example
of a cell that uses this.
So over here now we have
still our copper system.
So this is our cathode,
again, over here.
And a cathode does what,
oxidation or reduction?
AUDIENCE: Reduction.
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
There's a reduction.
And so this is our
same reaction, copper
plus 2, two electrodes,
coated copper solid.
So this is doing
the plating again.
But this time it's different.
Before we have the
zinc on an electrode
that was being consumed.
But now we have this platinum.
And the reaction that happens
at the anode-- it's still
an oxidation, always an
oxidation at the anode.
But the oxidation
reaction is chromium
plus 2 going to chromium
plus 3 and an electron.
So here, the electrode is
inert, and the reaction
is all happening
in the same phase,
all happening in solution.
So we can also write the
notation for this kind of cell.
And so here we would
have platinum solid,
the single line, which
means the phase difference.
Chromium plus 2 aqueous
comma, because now there's
not a phase transition between
these, a chromium plus 3
aqueous.
The two lines, that means what?
What do those mean again?
AUDIENCE: Salt bridge.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Salt bridge.
So this indicates
that's one beaker.
This is the other beaker.
And here we have the
copper plus 2 aqueous,
single line for phase
change and a copper solid.
So again, our anode reaction
and our cathode reaction.
All right, so this
is another kind.
You can also use platinum
electrodes in combination
with what's known as
a hydrogen electrode.
So these are often together,
the platinum with the hydrogen.
And many reduction potentials--
and when you get problem set
eight, you're going to be
looking up in your book
a lot of standard
reduction potentials.
And many of them will
say, measured against SHE.
And a lot of people
say, who is this SHE
that measures all
of these potentials
in the back of books?
And that SHE is a standard
hydrogen electrode.
All right, so let's
think about how
this electrode is being used.
So when it's used as a cathode,
we have H plus aqueous phase
transition to H2 gas, and
then another phase transition
to our solid platinum
inert electrode.
And here when it's
used as a cathode,
H plus is being reduced.
But it can also be
used as an anode.
And this is a clicker question.
Why didn't you tell me
what would be happening
when the hydrogen
platinum electrode is
being used as an
anode, or reaction's
being used an an anode?
10 Seconds.
Let's see if you can
get 90%-- 89, 89%.
Oh, far away.
That is the right answer though.
So some of these,
platinum is inert,
so it's not doing anything.
And it's over here.
So it's not doing anything.
So we can rule
out all the things
that platinum are doing stuff.
All right, H plus being
oxidized-- you ever
heard of H2 plus?
No, so we don't want that.
We know at the anode
it should be oxidized,
so we can eliminate all
the ones that are reduced.
OK, so we only have really
kind of one good option if you
say that the platinum is inert.
So H2 then gets oxidized in
this case, forming H plus.
All right, so let's look
at a cell like this that
uses the hydrogen electrode.
So here's an example.
Now on this side we have
our regular zinc system
for our anode.
And so over here we're using,
as the cathode, the hydrogen
electrode.
And so here in this beautiful
drawing that I made,
we have a glass tube
here where you're pumping
H2 gas in at 1 atmosphere.
In the middle of the tube
we have our inert platinum
electrode.
And then these are H2
gas bubbles down here.
And we have strong acid HCl,
which is our source of H plus,
in solution.
So over here again,
this is our cathode.
So we have a reduction
at the cathode.
And we have H plus aqueous,
phase transition H2, and gas,
and then another
phase transition
to our solid platinum electrode.
And over here is our standard
anode, our oxidation, that
involves zinc and zinc plus 2.
So we could also have had the
hydrogen electrode over here as
well.
All right, so that
gives you a number
of different examples
of types of electrodes
that you could have and types
of cells that you can have.
And that is the end of this,
today's-- or lecture 25 notes.
And as soon as you
finish writing that down,
we'll go and look at lecture 26.
Again, we're continuing
on the same theme.
And now we're going to
talk about the potential
of these cells.
So we've talked about
the reactions happening
at anodes and cathodes,
how to write them.
And now we're going to think
about the change in potential
that occurs when you
run these reactions.